hi I'm Peter Brinkman an engineer on the
speech infrastructure team in New York
and today I'd like to tell you about my
twenty percent project the patch field
audio architecture for Android in a
nutshell the idea is to allow you to
implement audio functionality such as
synthesizers and effects with minimum
fuss and to patch them together in a
patch field as you would in a recording
studio the core of patch field is a
service that manages the signal
processing graph and it also acts as a
central hub for audio so the service
managers all your audio units such as
synthesizers or effects and it provides
all kinds of functionality for and for
connecting them now you can run the
service locally in your app or remotely
when it's running locally then
essentially it gives you a powerful way
of organ organizing audio within your
app and it gives you also a couple of
other nice features such as support for
metaphor multiprocessors when it's
running remotely you get an added
feature namely you get support for inter
app audio routing meaning that say you
might have one app that just acts as a
synthesizer you may have another app
that acts as an effects rack you can
connect them and then all your signals
will flow from one app to another and
you get a lot of flexibility that way
now in terms of AP is there are two AP
is for you to work with there's a
gunshot there's a client API in Java and
the purpose of that Java API is to let
you query and manipulate the signal
processing graph so you can get a list
of the audio modules that are currently
available you can connect all your
modules you can disconnect them you can
enable or disable them and you can do a
number of other things as well and the
second API is the audio app module API
itself that one works with Java as well
as C and that's what you use for
implementing new audio functionalities
such as well synthesizers and
effects all right let's bring up a
little control app for patch field so
right now you see we have an on/off
button for enabling or disabling audio
processing and right off the bat we get
to audio modules we get one for the
microphones of the device so we see 11
audio module that has two outputs one
for one for each of the built-in
microphones and we see another audio
module with two inputs and those are the
inputs for the left speaker and for the
right speaker and for example I might
say connect one of the microphones to
one of the speakers and if I were to
turn audio processing on right now we
would get horrible feedback so let's not
do that instead let's launch another app
so this one is a very simple app that
just loads a WAV file and gets ready to
play it and when we go back to our
control app we see that a new audio
module has appeared and so now we
haven't have an audio module for our wav
file and let's bring up yet another
little app so here this app provides a
low-pass filter and once again if I go
back to the control app doesn't there's
a new module right here that represents
our low pass filter and now we can
connect them say I I send the audio from
the wave file into the low pass filter
and i sent the output of the low pass
filter to the speakers and now if i turn
on all your processing we hear the wave
fun
now we can go to our low pass filter and
if we play with the cutoff frequency you
can tell that the higher frequencies go
away some of the low pass filter acts as
expected
okay so so that was the core
functionality of patch field in a
nutshell all right let's take a look at
the code the patch field service
implements an interface called eyepatch
field service and this interface
consists of three types of methods you
have methods for manipulating the state
of the patch field service you have
methods for querying the state of the
service and you have methods for
internal use so so when you're
manipulating the state of the service
you can for instance you can turn on or
off all your processing that's what the
on/off button in the control app was for
that we saw a minute ago you can
activate and deactivate modules you can
connect ports of modules or you can
disconnect ports so essentially you can
you can make the changes that you would
expect and then you have matching
methods that tell you for instance
whether two ports are connected you can
get a list of the audio modules that are
currently installed and you have a
number of other methods as well so now
if you're implementing a pageview client
and you would like to keep up to date on
changes in the state of the patch viewed
service then you can implement this
eyepatch view client interface and now
if you register now if you register
yourself with the patch field service
you will get callbacks whenever
something happens so you might get a
call back when a module is created or
when a module is deleted when ports are
connected or disconnected and so on
so this was essentially bookkeeping the
interesting part really is the audio
module API because that's where you
implement audio functionality so the
foundation of it is a class called audio
module and it's an abstract test that
has four methods that you will need to
implement the most important of those
methods is one called configure where is
it here and the purpose of the configure
method is to connect your audio module
object to the corresponding data
structures in the patch field service
and let's see how this works in practice
so let's look at the Lopez module that
we saw in action in our little demo so
here's a module called Lopez module and
it extends the audio module class that
we just saw and sure enough it
implements the configure method that I'm
that I just mentioned so now this
configure method internally just takes
the handle that it received before and
the number of channels that it wants and
sends it to the two I native method
called configure native components so
let's look at the implementation of that
native method that's in a file called
low-pass see it's right here and this
method allocates space for a data
structure that will hold all the
information that characterizes our low
pass filters such as update coefficients
and filter values and then it goes ahead
and initializes the data structure and
now from the point of view of the API
the most important call is this one
right here there's a there's a function
called am configure and that one
establishes learn the connection between
your audio module and the patch field
service so this configure method takes
the handle that you received earlier so
you just so you receive the handle in
in the configure method and you just
hand it over to this function call it
right here then it takes a process
function that you implement in and that
provides the audio processing capability
that you want and then you give it the
data structure that we just created okay
let's take a look at our audio
processing function it's right here so
so this one initially just retrieves the
data structure that we allocated earlier
and then it it extracts the filter
update coefficient from from this data
structure and there's one crucial point
in here mainly it retrieves this update
coefficient using a a GCC built-in
called sync fetch and or and the point
here is to access this coefficient in an
anatomic way because we need to worry
about thread safety here this
coefficient may be changed by a
different thread when when you change
when you move the slider in the UI then
the UI thread will change this
coefficient but we're in the audio
thread here and so we might mean we need
to make sure we're properly synchronized
and this this GCC build and takes care
of that okay so now once we've retrieved
outfit filter update coefficient in a
thread-safe fashion we can do the actual
signal processing and that's happening
right here so we iterate over our
buffers we read our input samples we
perform our signal processing magic and
we write our output buffers so in
particular if you've studied signal
processing then you will recognize this
line right here this is just the update
formula of a simple RC low-pass filter
and that's it as far as the code is
concerned alright so that's it for now
you can find the source code at github
and there's a forum at Google Groups and
don't hesitate to to get in touch if you
have any questions or comments
happy hacking